écrire ça demande une grande
concentration moi je perds le fil quand
j'entends mon chien boire alors imaginez
en pleine guerre egle lui écrit au son
des canon de l'armée napoléonienne qui
approche de Yenna la ville du centre de
l'Allemagne où Hegel donne des cours
privés à l'université il achève son
livre inextrémist il met un point final
la nuit qui précède la bataille mais
voilà l'armée de Napoléon ravage la
ville des soldats pillent le logement de
Hegel menacé par ses hommes le
philosophe trouve refuge chez des amis
il a tout laissé derrière lui dans ses
poches il y a les pages du livre qu'il a
fini d'écrire au dernier moment ce livre
sauver des combats et des incendies
c'est la Phénoménologie de
[Musique]
l'Esprit vous avez déjà entendu parler
de Hegle vous avez déjà essayé de le
lire egle passe pour le philosophe le
plus difficile à comprendre c'est
simplement impossible pour un étudiant
de découvrir la pensée de egle en
s'attaquant directement au texte gle a
la réputation d'être un universitaire
très abstrait pour parler gentiment il
il passe aussi pour un homme ultra
rigoureux obsédé par les règles il ne
connaîtrait que la vie des idées parce
qu'il aurait passé la sienne dans les
livres mais tout ça c'est la légende
egle a en réalité eu une vie très
mouvementée et très intéressante et ce
que j'ai découvert en lisant ces
biographies c'est que toute une partie
de cette vie est restée cachée pendant
bien longtemps vous voulez connaître la
vérité sur gel et sans vous prendre la
tête bien sûr alors écoutez-moi jusqu'au
bout nous sommes dans les années 1770 à
seulement 5 ans entre à ce qu'on appelle
l'école latine le latin était encore la
langue de l'éducation et de l'érudition
en Occident et quand Hegel entre dans
cette école latine il connaît déjà la
première déclinaison du latin celle des
mots qui se terminent en a il sait déjà
du latin à 5 ans et bien oui c'est pas
un mythe et il y a une explication
simple c'est sa mère qui l'a initié au
latin à la maison les grands penseurs
sont souvent le fruit d'une stimulation
précoce et ele ne fait pas exception sa
mère est une femme cultivée qui se
soucie beaucoup de l'avenir de son fils
c'est rare à l'époque qu'une mère de
famille ait reçu une éducation assez
poussée pour être capable de faire la
prof pour ses enfants c'est vrai pour la
mère de Hegel comme ça l'avait déjà été
pour la mère de Kant ça montre que le
savoir était vraiment valorisé chez les
Hegel c'est en partie dû à leur milieu
la famille de Hegel appartient à la
bourgeoisie intellectuelle le père a
étudié le droit à l'université et il
occupe un poste dans l'administration
judiciaire et puis la mère et la fille
d'un avocat elle aime les livres et
c'est clairement elle qui transmet à
Hegel l'amour du savoir mais elle meurt
lors d'une épidémie de disenterie
lorsque Hegel a 11 ans après le est sur
la même longueur d'onde par exemple il
paye à egle des cours particuliers de
math et de français alors même que la
famille n'est pas
riche en France on a ce qu'on appelle la
classe préparatoire c'est l'étape la
plus difficile du parcours d'une partie
de l'élite scolaire de la nation les
étudiants passent de ou 3 ans à préparer
les concours de ce que le système
français appelle les grandes écoles ils
ressortent souvent transformés de ces
deux trois années de préparation parce
qu'ils ont abattu un gros volume de
travail intellectuel dans un contexte
d'urgence et de concurrence et bien heel
fait un peu la prépa de l'époque en
Allemagne sauf que pour lui c'est 5 ans
à 18 ans il entre au séminaire
lutherérien de Tubingen dans le Ducher
de wtenemberg au sud de l'Allemagne à 50
km au sud de Stuttgart un séminaire
luthérien ça forme des étudiants à la
théologie protestante lutherérienne et
le débouché naturel de cette formation
c'est pasteur c'est-à-dire le guide de
la communauté religieuse protestante ou
bien prof de théologie le séminaire de
tubingun est particulièrement réputé
comme Hegel est premier de sa classe au
lycée de Stuttgart il obtient une
coursese pour le séminaire de Tubingen
il y aura un mode de vie comparable à
celui d'un élève de prépa en France
travail intellectuel intense notamment
en théologie surmenage et concurrence
scolaire mais il y a en plus une stricte
discipline religieuse il faut se
soumettre à divers rituels religieux et
les livres qui ne sont pas conformes à
la ligne religieuse officielle sont
interdits les étudiants liscant et
Rousseau en cachette par exemple ces
conditions difficiles rapprochent eegle
de deux autres étudiants avec lesquel il
partage sa chambre et qui deviendront
eux aussi des grands noms de la culture
allemande le poète Erlin et le
philosophe of shelling les trois Génies
en herbe egel uerling et shelling
partagent également la même curiosité et
le même rejet du conditionnement
intellectuel du séminaire il se stimule
mutuellement étant donné la logique du
désir plus les profs et l'administration
interdisent les idées originales plus
les élèves s'y intéressent au point que
Hegel et ses deux amis deviennent fan de
la Révolution française qui se produit
au milieu de leur scolarité il fête
l'événement et une légende dit même que
Hegel et Erlin assistent à la plantation
d'un arbre de la liberté sur le marché
de Tubingen ce qui est un acte politique
assez risqué à l'époque bref les trois
amis détestent l'atmosphère idéologique
du séminaire du coup ils refusent leur
destin tout tracé ils ne seront ni
pasteur ni
théologien mais si Hegel ne veut être ni
pasteur ni théologien il va faire quoi
contrairement à Descartes qui
disposaient de plusieurs domestiques ou
contrairement plus tard à Schopenhauer
qui a hérité de son père contrairement à
eux et guul n'est pas rentier donc il
faut bien qu'il trouve un moyen de
gagner sa vie et bien à l'époque il n'y
a pas 1000 solutions quand on allit
érudition de egle et qu'on ne sait rien
faire d'autre on devient précepteur
c'est-à-dire prof particulier permanent
Kant a été placé dans la même situation
egle et ses deux amis Erling et shelling
acceptent tous les trois des positions
dans des familles nobles ou riches à
leurs yeux c'est moins difficile et
moins humiliant qu'un emploi religieux
mais à l'époque précepteur c'est
vraiment pas le top en fait c'est le
même niveau qu'un domestique le
précepteur est complètement soumis à ses
employeurs et il subit souvent leur
mépris c'est d'autant plus difficile
pour des jeunes fraîchement sortis du
prestigieux séminaire de Tubingen qu'ils
ont conscience de leur supériorité
intellectuelle le poète Erlin un de la
bande des trois avec egel et shelling
Erlin s'enfuit à plusieurs reprises de
sa place de précepteur une fois c'est
parce qu'il a une relation avec la femme
de son maître ele lui n'est pas si
maltraité il fait d'abord 3 ans dans une
famille aristocratique de Bern
l'actuelle capitale de la Suisse il a sa
propre chambre les maîtres l'admettent
parfois à la table familiale et en plus
il lui laisse du temps libre pour
poursuivre ses propres études d'un côté
c'est pour lui une riche expérience
sociale c'est un poste d'observation
pour comprendre l'élite social et le
système politique suisse egel parvient
également à s'introduire auprès de
personnages intéressants dans les
mondanités suisses mais de l'autre côté
il souffre de son isolement intellectuel
et il a le sentiment de perdre sa
jeunesse après Bern il fera encore 3
années à Francfort au centre de
l'Allemagne cette expérience de
précepteur n'est pas anodine dans le
desstin de Hegel en effet les
précepteurs sont le vivier de l'élite
intellectuelle allemande de l'époque
essentiellement les profs et les
écrivains ils sont statistiquement une
infime minorité de la population mais
ils sont des personnages
important dans beaucoup de romans et de
pièces de théâtre tout simplement parce
que les auteurs puisent dans leur vécu
on peut imaginer que c'est son
expérience de précepteur qui a inspiré à
Hegel sa fameuse dialectique du maître
et de l'esclave elle a probablement
aussi renforcé sa conscience politique
libérale nous sommes en octobre 1808 et
guule a 38 ans il vient de recevoir un
blâ du gouvernement bavarois qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait pour mériter ce blamame il
a dévoilé des informations concernant la
rencontre entre l'empereur Napoléon et
le tsar Alexandre 1er de Russie alors
même qu'elle n'est pas terminée le
gouvernement bavarois somme egle de
dévoiler ses sources il refuse mais
attendez pourquoi est-ce que Hegel
diffuse des informations concernant une
rencontre diplomatique et bien parce
qu'à l'époque il est journaliste et
parce que Hegel fait bien son travail
toujours un an plus tôt il a fu Yenna
ravagé par l'armée napoléonienne il se
retrouve à 36 ans à Bamberg à 200 km au
sud de Yenna pourquoi cette ville parce
qu'un ami lui a déniché un poste dans un
journal local egel et journalistes de
mars 1807 à novembre 1808 et il
travaille avec probité Zè et esprit
critique non seulement il cherche les
meilleures informations et il s'efforce
de les communiquer de manière vivante
mais il s'intéresse aussi au détails
techniques il cherche un papier de
meilleure qualité il fait en sorte que
les caractères d'imprimerie soient plus
nets mais voilà il se rend compte à quel
point la presse c'est compliqué moi j'ai
fait un stage dans un grand journal
français il y a 10 ans et je me souviens
que mon maître de stage m'avait dit dès
les premier jours surtout ne deviens pas
journaliste à l'époque de Hegle c'était
déjà financièrement difficile mais en
plus il y avait une censure étouffante
ele en est victime et quand il tient
tête au gouvernement bavarois qui veut
ses sources c'est parce qu'il sait déjà
qu'il va quitter le journal son ami
toujours le même lui a décroché un poste
de proviseur de lycée à nuramber à 60 km
au sud de Bamberg là il n'est pas embêté
par les autorités mais c'est quand même
la galère les bâtiments du lycée sont
véuste sous-équipés et il n'y a même pas
de toilett fonctionnelle egle doit
trouver lui-même une solution il n'y a
pas d'argent ni d'administration digne
de ce nom le chaos ambiant ne favorise
pas la discipline des élèves qui fume et
se battent en duel dans le lycée Eagle
lui-même est logé dans un appartement
vetuste et il ne reçoit son salaire
qu'irrégulièrement à cause de l'anarchie
qui règne en Bavière mais bon il fait
face il fait du mieux qu'il peut avec ce
qu'il a et d'après les témoignages la
situation du lycée s'améliore
progressivement cette anecdote montre
que contrairement à ce que l'abstraction
de la philosophie de Hegel nous laisse
imaginer il n'a pas passé sa vie à
l'université et dans les bibliothèques
il a une certaine expérience concrète et
pas des moindres cela montre aussi que
le succès intellectuel de Hegle est
tardif il a presque 40 ans et il n'est
même pas prof
d'université je vous l'ai dit lorsque
Hegel est proviseur c'est une période
difficile mais tout n'est pas sombre
dans le tableau en effet gel a trouvé
une fiancée la jeune belle et noble
Maria qui a 20 ans de moins que lui avec
elle il pense pouvoir trouver le bonheur
conjugal donc la veille de la cérémonie
de mariage il est confiant en l'avenir
sauf qu'il y a un souci et pas des
moindres il n'a pas l'argent pour la
cérémonie on lui doit toujours 5 mois de
salaire et il va devoir annuler sa
cérémonie de mariage s'il ne les reçoit
pas d'ici peu mais même s'il reçoit son
salaire en temps et en heure cela ne
changera rien à sa situation e gule est
pauvre du coup le père de sa future
femme était réticent il a d'abord
conditionné son accord à l'obtention
d'un poste à l'université par Hegel mais
étant donné que lui non plus n'avait pas
un rond il n'a pas pu imposer sa
condition et puis Hegel est quand même
proviseur avec un potentiel avéré de
philosophe ce qui lui confère un certain
prestige social la misère des
universités dû à la guerre a retardé le
dessin de Hegel sa pauvreté est même une
des causes de l'obscurité de son style
Une une fois marié ses besoins
financiers sont plus élevés donc il
écrit à la hâte le livre dont il espère
qu'il sera son chefdœuvre la Science de
la logique il y en a pour plus de 1200
pages dans les éditions modernes il faut
certainement une année à temps plein au
moins ou plusieurs années pour arriver
au bout d'un travail aussi colossal sans
parler de la complexité du propos mais
egle écrit le livre dans la
précipitation au cours des 6 premiers
mois de son mariage ça ne rend pas les
soirées des jeunes mariés très amusante
mais j'ai besoin d'argent pour vivre
confesse egle et puis un ouvrage
fondamental de philosophie comme la
Science de la logique ça va augmenter
ses chances de décrocher un poste à
l'université il y parviendra 5 ans plus
tard c'est-à-dire à 45 ans à
l'université de Heidelberg à 200 km à
l'ouest de nurberg il sera enfin reconnu
comme philosophe au sens culturel et
administratif son salaire donnera enfin
une base économique solide à sa vie de
famille mais sa longue pauvreté ne sera
pas anodine même prof à l'Université et
guul est bien loin de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la fuck you money
c'est-à-dire un niveau de richesse qui
assurerait une totale liberté de parole
egle lui ne peut pas dire n'importe quoi
car il a une famille à nourrir donc il
est prudent c'est un point qui fait
débat mais je pense que la pauvreté et
la dépendance de Hegel sont le facteur
principal de l'obscurité de ces texte
philosophique en effet cette obscurité
rend Hegel inclassable il n'est jamais
ouvertement contestataire sinon il finit
en prison et il n'est pas non plus
explicitement réactionnaire pardon pour
l'interruption mais j'ai une question à
vous poser vous croyez vraiment que les
gens ont lu tous les livres dont il
parlent bien sûr que non sinon on ne
pourrait pas parler de grand-chose et
oui il y a 24 Hees dans une journée et
il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le
chien donc le secret de la culture
générale ce n'est pas de lire des livres
c'est quoi alors en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivées les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets vous savez vous avez lu
Renant comme moi mais il se gardent bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'ils appliquent les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet ils brillent par
leur culture dans les conversations et
dans les débats et ils ont le recul
nécessaire pour faire preuve d'esprit
critique ça vous intéresse et bien je
vous révèle les cinq secrets et je vous
explique comment les appliquer dès
aujourd'hui pour vous cultiver 10 fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo c'est l'histoire
de 10 secondes donc faites-le maintenant
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier
secret qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire bonne
vidéo l'adolescent qui commet un vol
c'est un classique auquel beaucoup de
parents sont confrontés en plus le fils
de Hegle a volé une somme dérisoire
probablement l'équivalent de 5 ou 10 €
aujourd'hui mais le père monte sur ses
grands chevaux il fait retir tirer à son
fils son patronyme il n'est plus digne
de s'appeler egle en fait le vol n'est
pas la raison du retrait du patronyme
c'est le prétexte et pourquoi cette
sanction parce que ce fils qui s'appelle
Louis est gênant depuis bien longtemps
ce n'est pas l'enfant de Madame heegel
c'est un enfant antérieur au mariage et
dont la mère était la logeuse de Hegel
haenna Louis est ce qu'on appelle à
l'époque un fils naturel c'est-à-dire un
fils né hors mariage lorsque Hegel avait
37 ans apparemment sa mère était
vraiment amoureuse de Hegel il semble
qu'il lui ait promis le mariage et il
semble qu'elle l' est empêché de
retrouver une femme en vain comme je
vous l'ai dit mais Louis lui est resté
dans la vie de Hegle et il cause les
plus grands soucis à son père à partir
de son mariage il l'empêche de vivre
normalement gle a pourtant obtenu de sa
femme qu'elle accepte d'intégrer Louis
dans la famille il lui a fait suivre la
même scolarité que ses autres enfants au
lycée français de Berlin mais Louis est
malheureux partout la relation perfice
est tendue les malentendu et les
conflits se multiplie malgré leur
tentative de réconciliation egle et
Louis se blessent souvent l'un l'autre
le père prime supplie le fils FuG le vol
et la goutte qui fait déborder le vase
Louis ne s'appellera plus ele c'est
terrible parce que ça signifie que le
père Reny désormais le fils qu'il avait
pourtant reconnu et dont il avait
véritablement pris soin la fin de
l'histoire est tragique eegle achète à
son fils qui a alors 18 ans une charge
d'officier dans l'armée coloniale
hollandaise Louis quitte donc la famille
pour le service de la Hollande il ne
donne pas de nouvelle pendant 5 ans et
il meurt aux Indes à 24 ans les
partisans et les deux fils légitimes de
Hegel thèsent l'existence de Louis pour
diverses maison à l'époque un fils
naturel est une honte et donc les
adversaires de Hegle pourraient se
servir de cette information et puis ça
colle mal avec la réputation de Hegel
qui défend le respect des règles dans
tous les domaines donc l'existence de
Louis Hegel nous on peut lui rendre son
nom de famille l'existence de Louis
Hegel restera un secret jusqu'à plus de
60 ans après la mort du
philosophe je ne sais pas si vous vous
souvenez de l'ami grâce auquel Hegel a
obtenu un poste de journaliste puis le
poste de proviseur de lycée cet ami
c'est knit Hammer que Hegle a fréquenté
au séminaire de tubingun pour avoir
sorti egle de la panade deux fois en lui
trouvant les emplois de journalistes et
de proviseurs rien que ses faveurs font
de knit Hammer un super ami mais ça ne
s'arrête pas là c'est encore knit Hammer
qui a trouvé la femme de Hegel et c'est
grâce à ses conseils et à son influence
que le mariage se fait en dépit de la
pauvreté de Hegel et de son fils naturel
alors si on considère uniquement cette
amitié on se dit simplement que egle a
un super ami qui fait un peu office
d'ange gardien sauf que cet ami n'est
pas le seul à aider egle ce qui est
assez étonnant c'est qu'à de nombreuses
reprises systématiquement en fait
egle reçoit de l'aide lorsqu'il est dans
le besoin il a besoin d'un emploi on lui
trouve un emploi il a besoin d'argent on
lui em prête voir on lui donne il a
besoin de placer son fils naturel on
s'en occupe il veut se marier on lui
trouve une femme il veut donner des
cours à l'université il bacle une petite
thèse et le jury lui accorde le titre de
docteur bref l'impression qu'on a en
considérant le parcours de Hegel c'est
qu'il est au centre d'un puissant réseau
d'entraide et ce réseau c'est la
franc-maçonnerie je cite ce livre pour
pour vous montrer que je ne délire pas
le biographe se lasse presque de
retrouver tant de franc-maçons autour du
philosophe ce n'est pas étonnant parce
que la franc-maçonnerie de l'époque même
si elle regroupe une diversité
d'orientations idéologiques la
franc-maçonnerie de l'époque est en
partie un grand réseau d'intellectuel
progressiste il est donc naturel pour un
partisan des idées des Lumières un fan
de la Révolution française comme Hegel
d'être maçon or les franc-maçons se
considèrent comme des frères ils sont
tenus au sein de chaque loge par un
devoir d'assistance mutuelle ça sera
bien utile à egle dont le savoir est la
seule ressource en effet il intègre
assez tôt la société secrète lors de sa
première mission de précepteur en Suisse
pour sa seconde mission de précepteur il
offici chez les gogles une famille de
négociants extrêmement riches très
impliqué dans la fran-maçonnerie les
gogles ont même joué un rôle important
dans une autre organisation secrète les
Illuminés de Bavière qui sont à
l'origine de la légende moderne des
illuminatis cette société secrète a été
dissoute pendant l'adolessence de Hegel
mais la fraternité entre ses membres
perdure apparemment egel est au courant
donc pour persuader les gogle de le
prendre comme précepteur il leur écrit
un poème intitulé husis qui reprend des
thèmes et des symboles des Illuminés de
Bavière ce poème est une profession de
foi c'est une manière de dire au Google
qu'il appartient déjà à leur
famille nous sommes dans les années 1820
Hegle est un des pontes de l'Université
de Berlin qui est alors la plus riche et
la plus prestigieuse de toute
l'Allemagne egle a une grande influence
il est une star intellectuelle un jour
il apprend qu'un de ses élèves est
emprisonné pour raisons politiques les
amis du u perçoid des gueules que son
élève est innocent alors le professeur
participe à une expédition avec eux il
passe en bateau à minuit sous la fenêtre
de la cellule du détenu et il parl avec
lui la conversation se fait en latin
comme ça les gardiens ne comprennent
rien cette visite est clairement
illégale il n'est pas impossible que des
sentinelles découvrent le bateau et que
les visiteurs se fassent tirer dessus
pourquoi egle prend-il ce risque parce
qu'il est un militant libéral et dans
l'Allemagne de l'époque les libéraux ce
sont les opposants politiques ceux qui
sur le modèle de la Révolution française
veulent la la fin de l'absolutisme
politique être libéral ça veut dire
vouloir que le pouvoir politique soit
légitime et limité une formule rendue
célèbre par un article de Hegel dit
qu'il ne concède au roi que le rôle de
mettre le point sur le i après Hegel est
un militant libéral très prudent il est
si prudent qu'il y a plusieurs théories
sur son engagement politique ceux qui ne
croient pas à la sincérité de son
libéralisme pensent qu'il est un agent
des autorités presque un infiltré qui
fait revenir les partisans des idées
nouvelles sur le droit chemin mais les
faits indiquent que l'engagement libéral
de Hegel est sincère il est admis dans
les cercles des opposants politiques il
soutient les associations d'étudiants
persécutés par le pouvoir et il fourre
son nez dans de nombreuses affaires
policières et judiciaires et comme le
montre l'expédition en bateau il rend
même visite à des détenus politiques
egle prend de véritables risques parce
que d'autres finissent en prison pour
moins que ça s'il peut se le permettre
c'est parce qu'il a de puissants
protecteurs au sein des élites en fait
une partie de l'élite allemande de
l'époque déteste eg mais une autre
partie est fan de lui donc tant qu'il a
des fans dans l'élite il peut prendre
des risques mais malgré tout tout il
reste très prudent il sait qu'il est
surveillé que les autorités lisent ces
textes et ouvrent son courrier mais ce
n'est pas nouveau pour Hegel il évolue
dans le secret depuis le début de la
vingtaine à l'époque les autorités sont
effrayées par les événements de la
Révolution française donc elle traquent
la moindre manifestation d'opposition
comme le jeune egle souhaite lui que la
révolution s'étende à l'Allemagne il
écrit en langage codé dans ses lettres
et il pratique un double langage par
exemple il peut écrire qu'il soutient
les autorités d'une manière dont il sait
que le destinataire de la lettre
comprendra qu'il veut dire l'inverse ça
ne fait pas de Hegle un révolutionnaire
mais il prend quand même de véritables
risques et il en prendra en fait toute
sa vie adulte il est donc faux de dire
comme Engels que egle est le philosophe
officiel de la Prusse egle n'est ni le
philosophe du pouvoir ni un pur esprit
au contraire il y a déjà chez lui un peu
de son disciple le plus célèbre qui lui
abandonnera totalement la prudence du
maître malgré le malaise que je
ressentais et le fait que je ne pouvais
vraiment pas comprendre ce qu'il disait
j'étais totalement en captivé c'est le
témoignage d'un étudiant de egle à
Heidelberg cet étudiant sera un de ses
plus fidèles disciples et il deviendra
même un de ses éditeurs donc vous vous
rendez compte l'étudiant dit je ne
comprends rien mais ça me fascine et il
n'est pas le seul en seulement 2 ans de
cours à l'Université de Heidelberg egle
passe de 5 à 70 élèves comment
l'expliquer et bien c'est que la
réputation de egel comme philosophe
s'explique en bonne partie par la
puissance de ce que les psychologues
appellent la preuve sociale ce concept
psychologique signifie qu'un individu a
tendance à penser ou à agir comme les
autres individus autrement dit nous
déterminons ce qui est bien en observant
ce que les autres pense être bien
comment un étudiant peut-il être fasciné
par un discours qu'il ne comprend pas
parce que beaucoup de gens dans les
cercles académiques allemands de
l'époque penseent que Hegel est un grand
philosophe qui expose des idées neuves
et profondes je pense que c'est ce
phénomène psychologique qui est à
l'œuvre parce que l'obscurité du
discours de Hegel a d'abord été un
handicap son obscurité c'est une raison
qui revient à plusieurs repris prise
lorsqu'on lui refuse un poste à
l'université comment expliquer que Hegel
soit si difficile à comprendre c'est
peut-être tout d'abord un défaut naturel
car ses profs lui reprochait déjà son
manque d'éloquence ensuite les partisans
de Hegle disent que ces idées sont si
originales et si profondes qu'il est
impossible de les exprimer de manière
intelligible ouais c'est bien commode
comme justification ça et puis comme le
discours est inintelligible on ne peut
même pas vérifier que les idées de Hegel
sont vraiment originales et profondes
mais à l'époque de Hegel c'est un peu
une mode depuis le succès de Kant les
fil philosop considère que le manque de
clarté du discours est presque la mesure
de la maîtrise philosophique une autre
explication possible c'est que
l'obscurité peut rendre le discours
fascinant on a l'impression qu'il recè
une vérité cachée que nous les initiés
qui faisons l'effort de déchiffrer ele
sommes les seuls à découvrir un secret
inestimable une autre explication qui me
paraît également crédible c'est que
l'obscurité permet à egle d'embrouiller
les senseurs ils ne peuvent rien lui
reprocher puisqu'ils ne comprennent rien
et puis de manière pragmatique les
censeurs estiment que des livres aussi
incompréhensibles ne risquent pas de
troubler les autorités enfin une autre
explication mais plus controversée est
que l'obscurité permet aussi à Hegel de
dissimuler les faiblesses de sa pensée
en effet egle écrit vite et il a
tendance à pas mal retoucher ses textes
un peu comme on colmate des fissures
dans un mur de brique je penche
personnellement pour cette dernière
explication parce que même les
spécialistes de Hegel qui se chargent de
traduire sa pensée en langage
intelligible ne sont pas d'accord entre
eux dans la société ouverte et ses
ennemis Carl Popper estime que Hegel a
en fait bluffé pour acquérir une large
audience et une notoriété egle écrit
Popper est un écrivain dont le style
indigeste a découragé jusqu'à ses plus
ardents apologistes eegle se moque de
ses
lecteurs nous sommes en 1831 l'épidémie
de choléra décline à Berlin même si elle
fait encore des victimes après avoir été
confiné les gens reprennent peu à peu
une vie normale la famille Hegle est
revenue à Berlin après s'être réfugié à
la campagne gle reprend ses cours et
apparemment il va bien mais un dimanche
matin il souffre de malaise alors on
annule les rendez-vous prévus et ont
fait venir les médecins ils estiment
d'abord que ce n'est pas le chéra et ils
sont optimistes puis ils changent d'avis
si si c'est bien le choléra et il
presccrient des médicaments Eagle décède
2 jours plus tard dans la nuit
officiellement il est mort d'un choléra
sans symptômes extérieurs sans symptômes
extérieur madame eel n'est pas
convaincue par le diagnostic elle sent
qu'il y a un loup pourquoi veut-on que
le grand philosophe soit mort du choléra
ce diagnostic permet aux autorités
d'éviter de potentiel troubles en effet
elle craignent que les obsecs de Eagle
servent de tri bun aux opposants de la
monarchie prussienne mais grâce au
diagnostic les autorités ont un prétexte
sanitaire pour interdire des obsèques
normales cependant la veuve de Hegel ne
l'entend pas de cette oreille elle se
bat pour imposer les obsèques que mérite
son mari et elle les obtient le
déroulement montre que les craintes des
autorités étit fondé une immense foule
se presse aux obsèques l'affluence
exceptionnelle des étudiants en
particulier est une manifestation
d'opposition au roi et au gouvernement
en revanche aucun membre du gouvernement
ni même de la Cour n'est présent c'est
que que le vent avait tourné pour Hegle
ces dernières années ses protecteurs
disparaissent les uns après les autres
et la partie de l'élite allemande qu'il
dérangeait était de plus en plus
puissante et puis les disciples de Hegel
n'ont pas sa prudence ils franchissent
allèigrement les limites qu'il avait
lui-même refusé de franchir la position
du maître était fragile ses ennemis
s'apprêtaient à l'abattre définitivement
la dernière manifestation de la prudence
de Hegel c'est donc peut-être d'être
mort à
temps si vous aimez l'esprit de cette
vidéo à savoir découvrir des choses
ressente en allant à l'essentiel et sans
se prendre la tête alors vous aimerez
probablement mon programme Culture
Express c'est un programme méthodique
pour devenir facilement une personne
cultivée en seulement quelques mois il
couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale vous maîtriserez les
connaissances essentielles sur
l'histoire de l'humanité sur l'histoire
de France en économie en science
politique en psychologie en science en
littérature en art en religion et en
philosophie vous ne saurez plus jamais à
cours de choses à dire et vous gagnerez
la confiance nécessaire pour briller en
toute circonstances vous pouvez en
savoir plus en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite ou bien sur
celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore en tapant directement
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran dans
la barre de recherche mais je pense que
la meilleure façon de vous donner une
idée du programme est d'écouter ce que
les membres ont à en dire Valentine qui
reconnaît l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenter pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliqué concentré il
n'y a plus qu'à recopier et à apprendre
ce travail est vraiment formidable et
passionnant Maxence m'écrit directement
dans les commentaires en dessous d'une
vidéo du programme la formation est
vraiment remarquable j'étais un peu
dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas c'est un vrai
travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui est une mémoire essentiellement
auditive le choix des thèmes et des
chapitres est pertinent et je trouve que
tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite à la fois précis mais sans
fioriture vincent lui fait carrément ma
pub j'ai d'ailleurs recommandé votre
formation à ma sœur qui travaille comme
diplomate la semaine dernière elle a
déjà eu l'occasion de mettre à profit
dans ses discussions les connaissances
que vous avez diffusé vous verrez
d'autres témoignages comme ceci dans les
commentaires si vous rejoignez le
programme et si vous vous inscrivez vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultat une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme
je vous rembourserez intégralement si
vous estimez que vous n'avez pas acquis
une solide culture générale si vous
voulez en savoir plus cliquez sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite ou
bien sur celui qui est dans la
description ou bien encore taper
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tiré partie de
ce programme et je serai ravi qu'il en
soit de même pour vous dans tous les cas
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu je suis
romain et vous vous étiez sur 1idé de
culture générale rappelez-vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la
[Musique]
pensée